is everyone getting along in the White
House there reports that the New York
contingent you mentioned Dina Powell you
mentioned Gary you and Jared and then on
the other hand you have rights Priebus
and and Steve Bannon that there are
warring factions within the White House
is there any truth for that whatsoever a
lot of these like palace trade stories a
house of cards Game of Thrones yeah I
try to I try to stay out of all that I
think that it is healthy and good to
have people who don't always agree on
every single issue you want that
diversity of opinion at the table and I
do think we have a lot of different
viewpoints at the table but they're not
at odds with one another I think anyone
you ask will say that that's a positive
thing and that's a productive thing and
that lends itself to a better outcome
but but there is tremendous there there
are great teams at the White House and
and a lot of the people doing so much
work every single day or not the names
that you're reading about on a regular
basis